جهه قال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد انه يعمل
على انقاذ الدوله ولن يتراجع عن ذلك
ووصفها سيد اتهامه بالعنصريه بانه محض
اكاذيب يطلقها من يريدون بث التفرقه
والفتنه بينه وبين من وصفهم بالاشقاء
لافارقه جاء ذلك ردا على اتهامات وجهت
اليه بعد دعوته مجلس الامن القومي التونسي
الى اتخاذ اجراءات عاجله ضد طالبين اللجوء
من الافارقه القادمين من دول جنوب الصحراء
بغيه العبور الى اوروبا
انا من تونس مراسل الجزيره سيف الدين بو
علاق سيف الدين اذن ما زالت موجه
الاعتقالات مستمره واخرها اعتقال جوهر بن
مبارك
بالفعل حسن موجه الايقافات مستمره منذ
بدايه الشهر الفارق على الاقل هناك خيط
ناظم بين هذه الايقافات اخرها ايقاف جوهر
مبارك وهو مؤسس او احد مؤسسي حمله مواطنون
ضد الانقلاب التي انخرطت في جبهه الخلاص
الوطني طبعا هذا ياتي بعد ايقاف رئيس
الحزب الجمهوري عصام الشابي والقياديه
الاخرى في جبهه الخلاص الوطني شيماء عيسى
تقريبا وفق المحامين يقولون ان القضيه
تتعلق بقضيه التامر على امن الدوله ضد
خيام التركي وبعد وعدد من رجال الاعمال
والسيسيين الذين يتهمون بقضيه تتعلق مثل
ما اشرت بالتامل على امن الدوله الداخلي
والخارجي على خلفيه سلسله اجتماعات تم
تنظيمها بين جميع هذه المكونات
يقولون انها تاتي كمبادره او اجل صياغه
مبادره من اجل توحيد المعارضه
ويقول ايضا نجيب الشابي يوم امس للجزيره
ان كل من يحاول ان يوحد المعارضه او يقارب
وجهات النظر بين مختلف مكونات الطيف
السياسي وانهاء حاله الانقسام سيكون
مستهدفا يقول ان نجيب شاب يقول ان عصام
الشاب وهو شقيقه بالمناسبه لا يمكن ان
يتامر على الدوله بل هو يناضل منذ عقود
بشكل
ديمقراطي ونضال سلمي ولا يمكن باي حال من
الاحوال ان يتامر على امن الدوله الرد
طبعا ياتي او التفسير او القراءه الرسميه
تاتي من الرئيس قيس سعيد الذي يقول ان
هناك من يستهدف امن الدوله ويستهدف شخص
الرئيس قيس سعيد بل وحتى
باغتيال الرئيس
السعيد وبالتالي هذه القضايا المرفوعه او
الملاحقات الامنيه لا تتعلق لا بالحقوق
ولا بالحريات حسن نعم شكرا لك سيف الدين
بوعلق من تونس